the marvel cinematic universe is more
omnipresent than ever before thanks to
the welcome addition of various disney
plus shows to its ever expanding phase 4
roster so far the marvel series on
disney plus have focused primarily on
characters we've met before in the mcu
wanda and vision get a taste of the
domestic life in wanda vision falcon in
the winter soldier is essentially a
buddy cop show that expands on the
relationship of avenger frenemies sam
wilson and bucky barnes loki learns of
the existence of a bureaucratic
organization beyond the confines of
space and time in his self-titled series
clint barton has to suit up once again
in hawkeye to the delight of fans the
dynamic of the disney plus mcu is about
to change on march 30th once stephen
grant aka mark spector aka moon knight
makes his debut played by oscar isaac
the mercenary who's imbued with the
power of an egyptian god just received
his first trailer for disney plus and it
looks like a movie quality production
with a compelling narrative centered on
a man working at a museum who stumbles
upon powers far beyond his control i
can't tell the difference
between my waking life
and dreams but of course there will be
time for discussions of plot points and
how the show ties into the rest of the
mcu later for now fans are marveling at
how iconic the titular character's
costume is marvel has done a great job
as of late giving characters comic
accurate costumes from wanda finally
donning her iconic red outfit to sam
wilson becoming his version of captain
america in the falcon and the winter
soldier it looks like moon knight will
be no exception and as evidenced in the
trailer he'll have his white costume
with some minor adjustments including
the fact his outfit wraps around him
like a mummy fans appear to be in
agreement with this redditor who neatly
summed up a lot of first impressions
posting that suit looked so
good
another happy fan wrote i am extremely
excited with the costume design
holy sh did they knock that out of the
park or what translates very well to
screen the costume is such an important
aspect of the character to get right so
the fact that marvel nailed it bodes
well for the rest of the series other
fans took the opportunity to have fun
with moon knight looking so good with
one redditor joking if he beat the out
of me i'd be too in awe of the suit to
notice
as fan chatter makes abundantly clear
people think it's a good thing that the
mcu is keeping moon knight's visuals as
comic book accurate as you can
reasonably expect this is certainly no
small feat considering that the
character's classic look is essentially
a white bodysuit with a mask and a
hooded cloak this looks cool on page but
keeping things too simple could
potentially be a disaster in live action
as such the added detail and the
off-white almost grayish color of the
suit adds to the effect
however there are also some significant
differences between the live-action and
comic versions of the suit as
good-looking as the mcu version is its
properties seem somewhat different to
the classic comic book version of the
moon knight costume that version of the
garment is a very earthly man-made super
suit with armor to protect its wearer
and a few cool yet comparatively
grounded gadgets plus a cloak that
doubles as a rudimentary parachute slash
gliding device in the comics at no point
does this costume wrap around its wearer
like a living thing if the moon knight
footage we've seen so far as any
indication the mcu iteration of the
costume might look like the original but
the general mummy vibes of the design
may indicate that the suit draws deeper
inspiration from egyptian mythology
considering the whole wraps around the
wearer situation there's a chance that
the suit might even have a mind of its
own not unlike doctor strange's cloak of
levitation would a sentient moon knight
suit be incredibly cool to watch no
doubt would it be bad news for mark
spector and all of his enemies alike
almost certainly
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
moon night are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you